uh
let's see
Crowder's back and he had a special
guest today oh boy
Bellum uh one morning and I was
surprised how everything was boarded up
I was very surprised when we came down
here in Sixth Street for people if we
can see everything going on everything
is boarded up
um you got all the black lives matter
edge of his stuff sprayed over it right
and if you try and paint over that or
for business owner does they can
actually be charged with a hate crime in
some cases it can be actually criminal
to wash your own wall that's right now
financed communist anti-American
propaganda
on your property on your boarded up
business Alex is eating again huh
I think everybody's gained some
quarantine yeah of course I think what
Alex is among them uh is a civil right
and if you paint over it you can charge
the acronym yeah well there was a
business owner who will remain nameless
in Dallas who was like I just cleaned
that and then he just ended up having to
leave it up you know one guy who we
interviewed yesterday when we were doing
the change of mind said these boards
were up for so can you tell me is it or
is it more so the rioting and breaking
the windows it was both when it started
really six months ago here some of the
big corporations boarded up because they
were on the inside baseball that this
was going to be a permanent shutdown
until Trump was driven from office but
the smaller businesses tried to stay
open but then the city ordered them
closed but they didn't board up but
billions yeah that makes sense it's
really hard to find some of these
numbers for example uh you know my home
state of Michigan right they were going
to release the Am I Wrong Am I Wrong for
thinking they should have gotten a dolly
this would have made a great Dolly shot
yeah like a Scorsese film you know and
they do the whole walk down the street
they do like one big shot
covid nursing home yes well I think the
number at one point they said it was
close to 40 percent 40 something odd
percent of uh all coveted deaths were
nursing home deaths then they just
stopped counting them you can't find the
updated New York's doing the same thing
yeah yeah and we couldn't get them in
Michigan Governor Whitmer kind of
started never finished absolutely this
is this is startling I mean we talked
about it with deep I said Alex isn't
fatty just short for his ideal weight to
the core eagles says Jones used the term
inside baseball 12 times per hour now he
really does
um this is really a post-apocalyptic
here's
there's a lot of stuff that's
post-apocalyptic and some stuff that
we've seen
this doesn't look that post-apocalyptic
at least where they're walking down
right now
yeah particularly if if they're drawing
the murals on these boards that are
going to get taken down eventually I'm
not saying it's not annoying and I'm not
saying the business owner stuff isn't
[ __ ] up because it is of course it is
but I wouldn't call this Fallout but
it's it's yeah exactly I I I'm more
concerned with the guys getting pulled
out of trucks and kicked in the head
that's I'd like to nip that in the bud
before the murals it doesn't really
George he's the king
and the all on the back of us of this
sad guy who was just totally drugged out
yeah and
don't worry we're not talking about you
we're just talking about the guy in the
picture
Am I Wrong Stephen but I'm starting to
think these are getting pretty uppity
final form he can't be here Alex
drug addicts yeah but then they become
this symbol that the police
so basically our janitors for them now
they clean up their crap they take them
to the hospital and now if something
gets out of hand and there's a mistake
and something happens the police get
charged with murder right yeah it is um
did you watch the full body cam footage
it's very sad well it's very sad and I
think what's going to happen
unfortunately is you're going to see
more backlash because listen it's a
tragedy we always said it was an example
of Alex Jones is starting to walk like
Hank kills dad
I think Alex is just turning in to his
dad you talk Cotton Hill Cotton Hill
yeah
uh apparently somebody said that
Alex Jones went after Bill Burr
did he yeah there's a few minutes though
of Bill Burr the comedian up there
saying let's depopulate people on his
Netflix special here it is
take over exactly where it's leading and
what they're going to do to you and your
family and they're coming they're going
to shoot you up and you're never gonna
have kids again or you're going to get
cancer and die and they're going to have
liability protection and Bill Gates is
going to laugh about it I've been
spending a lot of time on
event 201 in lockstep where the
Rockefeller Foundation available
indicates Foundation admit they're
bringing in World Government
authoritarianism the end of an open-free
Society now I think Bill Burr is a good
comedian he's against cancer culture and
he's got courage to come out and
criticize it in this landscape of
cowards I mean in a world of cowards
a person with any courage is a hero
that's a scary thing and when the people
fear the government there is tyranny
when the government fears the people
there is Liberty as Thomas Jefferson
said but he did this whole special
on Netflix that he got into depopulation
and he said let's just say what we want
we need to depopulate the Earth
some areas are overpopulated some places
have taken up the resources but most
areas are not and you could sustain this
population if you remove
having 2.1 percent replacement rate for
every two adults two points he was
he was joking I think I remember the
whole joke was sink a cruise ship it was
a bit and I don't think bilper actually
wants to sink cruise ships and also you
know stanhope's done bits like that
before a lot of people have done bits
about that even people discussing it
um
seriously I'm all for some depopulation
if it's not done in an Insidious fashion
you know what I mean like there's ways
to educate people and and to to you know
what I mean to prevent people from going
to you know birth control you know not
not saying abortion but actual birth
control and stuff like that
um
but the idea
that we would pollute a little less and
probably not eat through resources as
badly
um it's it's not that that out there of
an idea that we shouldn't be if we're we
were we were like three billion I think
at the turn of the 20th century
something like that three four billion
and we've like doubled that and then
what if we double it again then we're at
14 billion in 100 like that's yeah
there's nothing wrong with saying that
that's unsustainable which is you know
the entire discussion that we have all
the time about getting off of planet
Earth and going to another place is
based on the fact that we know that we
can't sustain this growth I don't see a
problem there
well I think what I take from this is
like he's he is just it's a stand-up I
know he's just kidding but but it's like
this is kind of hysterical he's tying a
Bill Burr thing and I don't know he's
working with Bill Gates and he's going
to shoot you up give me cancer you gotta
have kids and you're like Bill Burrs
just doing the whole I think we should
kill everybody but what do I know it's
the same thing he's always done same
gimmick I don't think Gilbert has ever
stood up and said I'm an expert on
things which society collapses unless
you get rid of a human future and that's
what's happening right now as a
globalist Reclamation project the
sabotage civilization they opened up
house Fest
Globus Reclamation project bucketheads
in the band oh
and destroy the real carrying capacity
of the Earth have those that implement
the crisis Riot is the planetary rulers
and the saviors here's what the comedian
has
so they're all sitting there you know
that was just out six months ago and now
they're not allowed to go to hear
another human talk because the
clampdown's here oh you're like Yay kill
everybody oh well we're starting it
we're making you obsolete right now
getting rid of the infrastructure for
you worldwide depression hundreds of
millions are going to starve to death
and we're using billboard or normalize
it
stretch Alex I was watching F is for
family
but don't worry you're getting free
checks that first six months that first
year
some of you are the middle class is not
the poor people
oh no they're all having to move in with
Mama but mama don't have money no more
so oh there's gonna be more homeless oh
the collapse is here
and so a sick part of me is
all these 60 something millions of
babies we've killed nobody came to their
help so all these yuppies and trinitys
want to live in a dystopic new world
order and get exterminated well line on
up which some of the chat says Burris
and funny bird is funny I mean look you
might not like a lot of this political
stuff now but I think Burr's funny also
Alex dystopian it's pronounced dystopian
uh right let's see here
somebody in the chat said that Alex
Jones looks like a gigantic [ __ ]
wrestler
full-size ninja wrestler